hey 42 here if you've ever felt swamped
by the chaos of it all and crave some
time alone in nature why not venture to
groinart Island this remote lump of land
off the northwest coast of Scotland is
utterly uninhabited and devoid of
irritating modern conveniences like
Wi-Fi running water or reliable Shelter
encircled by the Frosty Waters of the
North Atlantic you could even satisfy
your ponchon for Cold Water swimming but
along with your Speedos you might want
to pack your hazmat suit and instead of
sun cream it's Scotland it's probably a
good idea to top up your vaccinations
specifically the kind that protects you
from deadly bacterial infections oh and
don't be alarmed if the locals refer to
your new holiday spots as the island of
death according to the British Ministry
of Defense it's perfectly safe to visit
well it is now anyway because for a
solid 50 years beginning in the early
1940s this two square kilometer island
in the arsene of nowhere was one of the
most perilous places on Earth thanks to
one of the most bizarre covert
operations of the second world war
operation vegetarian
despite the name it wasn't an assault on
Humanity's herbivores quite the contrary
it was a crazy campaign against
carnivores specifically the German ones
for that reason it was arguably one of
the most misnamed military campaigns of
the 20th century right up there with
operation toenails the invasion of new
Georgia by Allied troops operations red
bean and frequent wind which must have
been unpleasant for everyone involved
and operations Beaver cage and Viking
snatch the less said about those the
better operation vegetarian was a
proposed bio-warfare campaign during
World War II that aims to sabotage the
German food supply by contaminating
cattle with Anthrax the horrific
bacterial infection not the American
fresh metal band
though I'm sure Castle wouldn't like
that very much either the plan was the
brain fart I mean brainchild of British
scientist Paul Fields a distinguished
biology buff and who three years into
World War II was tasked with concocting
a biological weapon that could turn the
tide on Hitler his answer was simple
drop millions of Anthrax laced linseed
Cakes Across Germany during the summer
when the nation's Castle would be out
grazing if everything went to plan the
cattle would consume the cakes and
become infected subsequently infecting
the people who ate them
if it turned out that castle didn't like
the taste of Anthrax the cakes would
simply dissolve the next time it rained
poisoning the grass which the cows would
eventually eat anyway either way things
would end badly for the bovines
this whole plus I'm talking about in
this video sounds like something
imagined by a James Bond villain but
soon after it the Allies completed an
operation just as horrific the infamous
bombing of Dresden Germany whilst this
Firestorm resulted in massive civilian
casualties like operation vegetarian
promised to Dresden was also a strike at
the wealth of the German Empire to be
the city was filled with cultural wealth
and artifacts like sculptures and
artwork along with many German Elites
who hoarded such wealth their Obsession
for these fine artworks runs deep in
fact a German Art Market experienced a
boom during the war with work seen as
stable wartime Investments flash forward
to the 21st century and art stability as
an investment has still held over time
it's a strategy that used her only work
for the Uber Rich until today's sponsor
Masterworks cracked the market wide open
selling 45 million dollars worth of art
last year alone and returning the net
proceeds not to billionaires but to
people like you and me in fact every
Masterworks exit to date has returned a
profit with another two sales in just
the last few weeks with over 700 000
users Masterworks offerings have sold
out in minutes they even had to make a
wait list for new users but I've got you
special access to skip it so just click
the link in the description right now
don't miss out
the bacteria that causes Anthrax
bacillus anthracis can be inhaled
ingested or absorbed through direct
contact with the skin but the side
effects are ultimately the same sepsis
multiple organ failure and swelling of
the fluid and membranes around the brain
and spinal cord resulting in extensive
internal bleeding and eventually
cutaneous Anthrax the one you get for
your skin is the most common form and
inhalation Anthrax is the deadliest but
gastrointestinal Anthrax the one the
British plan to spread through operation
vegetarian isn't far behind left
untreated over half of gastrointestinal
Anthrax patients perish and even if
treated with the right antibiotics which
weren't around in 1942 anyway 40 percent
of patients don't make it Anthrax isn't
man-made bacillus and Francis is found
naturally all over the world mainly in
soil it mostly infects farmed and wild
animals who occasionally transmit it to
humans some Scholars think it was the
real cause of the fifth plague in the
Bible which describes the sickness that
A flicks Livestock today we still
witness roughly 2 000 cases annually but
operation vegetarian would have dwarfed
those numbers the plan was to
contaminate Germany's beef cattle
possibly infecting humans who tasted on
the meat but at the very least it would
have killed all the cows creating a
colossal food shortage that would force
the Nazis to reroute resources and
attention away from beating the crap out
of half of Europe but this logic was
flawed from the outset when Paul Phil
started his research Hitler and his
forces were at the peak of their
European expansion granting them access
to Food Supplies far beyond Germany's
borders
killing a lot of local cows would have
been horrible but it wouldn't have
starved the nation
so not a particularly pragmatic strategy
but that was far from the worst of it
operation vegetarian despite its
tree-hugging name was an ethical
catastrophe had it being carried out it
would have been impossible to control
the spread of Anthrax which would have
infected not only the targeted Castle
but many other animals humans and even
the land itself potentially killing
millions and rendering all of Germany
uninhabitable for Generations In
fairness the British didn't know all of
this at the time to discover anthrax's
full lethality they would firstly to do
the sciency bit and test the stuff and
for that they would need a remote
unoccupied area far away from people
especially people who like to ask
inconvenient questions which brings us
back to groinard Island your next dream
holiday
in 1942 scientists from Portland down
the government's biochemical research
lab in Southern England descended on
grenade Island taking 60 sheep along for
the company in the first test a modified
plane dropped an Anthrax bomb on the
island killing all 60 sheepies but also
some animals on the mainland nearby
later tests involving Anthrax cake bombs
caused more unplanned spread of the
disease when a contaminated sheep
carcass washed upon Shore across the bay
sparking an outbreak of Anthrax in local
animals and livestock the government
told Farmers a passing Greek ship was to
blame and washed everything up through
the Tactical use of some very generous
bribes I mean compensation despite their
collateral damage Anthrax bombs were
clearly a very deadly success groinard
Island was transformed into a forbidding
hellscape freshening death upon any
setting foot on its Shores so what did
the British military do to remedy this
environmental disaster carry Hauser for
a decontamination program restoring the
once pristine Island
nah they put up a big no entry sign and
buggered off now if you're thinking wow
those Anthrax experiments sound
terrifying thank God the British
abandoned the project and made
themselves a nice cup of tea instead you
would only be partially correct there
was almost certainly tea involved but
the devastating tests on gronard Island
didn't slow down operation vegetarian
quite the opposite inspired by their
Newfound ability to kill lots of living
things within a few days the British
military entered full-scale production
and by 1943 they'd stockpiled 5 million
Anthrax cakes ready for distribution
across Germany as the summer of 1944
approached operation vegetarian was
officially ready to bear fruit or
vegetables actually cakes whatever it
was ready but when the time came to
execute the anthrax apocalypse the need
for decimating an entire country with a
murderous pathogen had disappeared with
the successful invasion of Normandy
behind them the Allies were steadily
moving across Europe with the Nazis on
the retreat operation vegetarian was
abandoned and the 5 million anfrax cakes
were incinerated along with all the
taxpayers money that had gone into
making them I think I speak for everyone
and their cows were when I say thank God
Not only would it have been an act of
tremendous cruelty that would forever
have shifted the lines of what's
permissible in war the Brit still didn't
know the full potential of what they
were dealing with
yes they have proved Anthrax could be a
Lethal Weapon but they had no idea how
long its effects could last that they
discovered when they went back to groin
Head Island after the war scientists
assumed the anfrax contamination would
neutralize itself after a few years but
the spores proved to be incredibly
resilient and decontamination efforts
failed miserably groinard remained a
death trap for decades a fact that
became public knowledge when a Ministry
of Defense video was Declassified in
1980. the footage showed the experiments
has been performed almost 40 years
earlier in September including one bomb
dropped from an aircraft and the third
expedition was made in the following
summer when four trials were done with
the four pounder bomb sheep were used
for the trials because they're
particularly sensitive to inhaled
Anthrax and this resulted in a public
outcry just kidding no one really gave
it
well almost no one a small band of
revolutionaries calling themselves
rather ominously the dark Harvest
commander of the Scottish citizen Army
they gave lots of shits these Rebels
first announced themselves to the world
in 1981 when a mysterious note was
pinned to the front door of Saint
Andrew's house home of the Scottish
government in Edinburgh they claimed to
have assembled a crack team of hard
bastards that included at least two
microbiologists
and that state visited groinart Island
to collect over 100 kilograms of poison
soil this soil lay threatened would be
left in strategic locations around the
country until the government paid
attention shortly afterwards a package
of Anthrax soil was discovered at Port
and down the facility where operation
vegetarian was developed the dark
Harvest Commandos appeared to mean
business clearly unsettled the British
government sprang into action five years
later in 1986 the worst of the topsoil
was removed and everything Left Behind
was sprayed with a mixture of seawater
and formaldehyde in 1990 the quarantine
was finally lifted and groined Island
was officially declared safe ish to
visit in 1972 the biological weapons
convention was created Banning countries
from developing producing stockpiling or
using biological weapons 185 countries
signed up effectively making it illegal
for governments and militaries to muck
about with substances like anthrax
hopefully thanks to monstrous mistakes
like operation vegetarian were all
becoming a little smarter about the
downsides of mass destruction and can
look forward to a more peaceful world
for all of mankind and cows
thanks for watching